quand j'ai vu cette image de margaux
j'ai toutes les remontées je me suis dis
donc moi j'ai twitté en mai 2019 et je
me suis dit qu'est ce qui a changé
j'ai twitté parce que c'était mon
dernier recours face au silence de la
justice qui ne répondait pas aux
différentes infractions de mon ex
conjoint qui avait été remis en liberté
ce que j'avais peur de mourir j'avais
peur pour ma fille est en fait par
désespoir j'ai lancé un tweet ah mais
moi je n'ai pas pensé du tout à me
retrouver dans les médias en fait je
voulais quelqu'un m'aide et les réseaux
sociaux ils m'ont sauvé la vie mais
c'est pas la joie deux ans après ça
justement avant d'évoquer le le rôle des
réseaux sociaux j'aimerais qu'on revient
si vous le voulez bien sûr votre votre
histoire qui se débat qui se démarre
plutôt très bien c'est à dire comme une
histoire d'amour quand vous rencontrez
votre compagnon c'est au départ une
jolie histoire d'amour pas au départ
c'est le coup de foudre je le rencontre
travail c'est lui qui nous forme donc
tout et emilie votre supérieur
hiérarchique y avait un lien dire archi
oui en fait moi j'étais en intérim et
lui il est attaché commercial donc
c'était lui qui devait me former et là
tout de suite quitté sa compagne s'est
retrouvé à la rue bas du coup moi je les
berges et je me suis le pauvre il se
trouve à la rue pour moi donc c'est vrai
que tout de suite on a été ensemble ça a
été fusionnelle et la première gifle en
fait elle a commencé au bout de 4-5 mois
voilà il était rentré de soirée
alcoolisée en fait j'ai pas compris ce
qui s'est passé je suis resté en état de
choc et de sidération et le lendemain
quand je vais demander des explications
c'est la faute de l'alcool sont passés
aussi où son père avait été violent avec
sa mère est en fait j'ai pardonné la
première gifle salt incroyable et moi et
c'est que lorsqu'on entend les
témoignages de deux femmes qui subissent
des violences conjugales
notamment c'est que on entend ce schéma
se répéter c'est à dire le premier coup
la première gifle alors soit il ya le
facteur de l'alcool soit c'est parce que
j'étais stressée etc et on entend
régulièrement j'ai pardonné parce que le
pauvre en fait parce que ceci parce que
cela à aucun moment vous avez vous êtes
dit oui mais il faut peut-être partir
tout de suite maintenant jamais si j'ai
réussi à le quitter j'avais s'est acheté
un appartement ge avait emménagé chez
lui et dès le premier soir j'ai pas
compris son changement de comportement
il m'a dit t'es chez moi tu vas fermer
ta gueule
parce que ce que je te dis et là on a
commencé à monter d'un cran dans la
violence donc là il rentrait de soirée
souvent sous l'emprise de l'alcool et là
c'était d étranglement il me dénigrer
sur mon physique t'es qu'une merde c'est
dégueulasse personne ne voudra toi tu as
toujours pas trouvé de cdt qu'une fille
de banlieue et en fait je l' ai cru
j'étais complètement dévalorisé je
l'avais l'impression que j'étais plus
rien et à côté de ça il y avait les bons
moments qui efface tout et il ya un
matin j'ai pris deux gifles de trop donc
il n'était pas alcoolisé et là je suis
parti chez un collègue de l'équité mais
je les ai quittés en fait j'avais pas là
c'est la seule fois d'ailleurs où je l'
ai vu pleurer je lui ai dit c'est fini
s'écrouler par terre il m'a dit voilà
c'est une ma faute et je me suis dit il
faut que je parte et trois mois après
les revenus il m'a sorti le grand jeu je
t'aime je suis malheureux sans toi voilà
je sais qu'il ya des choses qui vont pas
dans mon comportement j'ai vraiment
envie de changer et je me suis dit dans
la vie on a tous eu droit à une seconde
chance donc je suis retourné avec lui je
suis tombée en masse et j'ai bien
devenus ces cas là à chaque fois donc on
entend que cette emprise à chaque fois
qu'on entend c'est de la femme qui se
remet en cause et et en l'occurrence là
en plus vous tomber enceinte et pendant
la période de la grossesse si je ne dis
pas de bêtise ça se calme alors ça se
calme les cinq premiers mois de
grossesse tout et des biens ils avaient
l'air d'être heureux et d'aller qu'ont
repris à cinq mois de grossesse et l'âge
et les rentrées de soirée je me doutais
là il m'a sauté dessus et je pensais
même pas que c'était possible de frapper
une femme enceinte c'est horrible et là
je me suis mis en fait selon plus moi je
mentais après je disais à tout le monde
regarde et il a changé alors que mes
proches mes collègues me disent mais
pourquoi tu es retourné avec lui donc
moi je disais à quel point c'est un
homme nouveau il avait changé et je me
suis mis ce que vous sentez coupable en
plus de ce qu'on vous pointe du doigt en
disant mais pourquoi tu es avec lui pour
moi tu fais ci pourquoi tu fais ça ah
oui j'avais des réflexes la double peine
ah mais oui j'avais les gens ne se
rendent même pas compte de leurs
réflexions regarder elle est enceinte
mais son biberon la petite halle b est
ce vrai à l'alcool enfin faut voir tout
l'entourage on fait des blagues mais ça
me fait mal et finalement je me suis mis
dans une bulle et après à l'accouchement
y avait plus d'excusés on est une
famille et il y à ce soir cette nuit du
16 au 17 avril 2018 ou là vous avez
vraiment cru qu'il allait vous tuer
abbas a fait depuis plusieurs mois en
fait qui menaçait parce qu'il y avait eu
une intervention de police en novembre
2010 et 2000 17 il y avait balancé une
bouteille d'eau froide sur ma fille est
sur moi à 11h 11h30 enfin tard le soir
là je suis demandé de partir de
l'appartement et j'ai eu peur son regard
noir j'ai appelé mes parents et là il
m'a repris mon téléphone il m'a menacé
de mort avec un club de golf j'ai cru
que j'allais mourir avec ma fille ella
et rigoler n'exige pas si je vais tuer
ta mère ton père le sdf la police mes
parents sont arrivés la police y est
arrivé et là j'ai eu un déclic j'ai
demandé aux policiers si je dépose
plainte qu'est ce qui va se passer et là
il m'a dit les menaces de mort c'est un
huis clos donc c'est ma parole contre la
sienne même si avec club de golf qui
étaient là et ma fille elle pleurait
elle était trempé il m'a dit ça va pas
être des coûts pour la justice donc il y
aura pas de suite donc je me suis
certain que je dépose plainte